I've always wanted to share the stage
with a creepy skull mannequin but why
that that's just fantastic um when I was
younger although not quite so young that
I should really not have known better um
I sent one of the most harsh messages I
have ever sent in my life and we share
it with you now I'm not proud of it but
here it is I've blocked you everywhere
else and now I'm going to block you here
too
my only regret is that I can't brought
you in real life past me was a dick I
couldn't block them in real life right
they were still in the same social
circles they were still gonna get
invited the same events I'm gonna pass
the same thing and it's going to be
awkward particularly after I send a
message like that and some folks would
say I should just get used to it I
should be you know I should just be at
peace with the fact that some people are
just jerks and some peeps and
personalities clash but I thought what
if instead we use technology to fix that
so my proposal for you my both of you
here tonight is blocking in real life
um which has been done in science
fiction right this is this is from Black
Mirror but the trouble with the trouble
with science fiction blocking is that
they have to make it work on camera and
that means inevitably it's it's a it's a
messy buzz of pixels or something like
that and that's not useful right that's
not helpful because a messy block of
pixel can still see you and you can
still see it and it can still punch you
in the face so that's that's not great
but we do have an algorithm for this
that will already work and Photoshop has
it's called content-aware fill and it's
the it said Wow whoo from a Photoshop
user that although given this audience
possibly the man who created the feature
we don't know um I was actually
originally in that photograph there and
that's the original but nowadays it's
trivial just find objects painted out
and there you go and if you didn't have
those two identical bushes right there
in the middle you might not even spot
that I was never there in the first
place
now Facebook already has facial
recognition to people right so in theory
you get a photo room here's one of me
and some friends you get a photo you
could highlight the person and you could
paint them that yellow
just go a little bit Cronenberg
sometimes but in the next few decades
we're going to figure out how to make
much much deeper connections into the
brain right we're already starting to
see some things like this we've been
using deep brain stimulation for
Parkinson's patients since 2006 that's
when that paper was from and spoiler or
if they insist on calling it here
abstract abstract it works I've already
got people are controlling robot arms
with brain implants and exoskeletons
with EEG caps okay so no one is actually
working like a neural light yet no of
course Elaan musk is worth beyond in
your life because I long musk is working
on everything that enn bikes ever wrote
about so let's say if it works let's say
that in the next few decades over the
rest of this century we get something
that starts to make deeper and deeper
connections into the brain and a start
off with it's going to help an
increasingly aging population to deal
with senescence but eventually it will
trickle out the restaurant ma'am I'm
going to bet that humanity won't regress
into virtual worlds because virtual
worlds are good for gimmicky games but
they're not real there's no real human
interaction there and sure the uncanny
valley has pretty much been solved right
that is Johnny Depp playing young Johnny
Depp in the latest pirates movie but you
can't have that for human interaction
I'm willing to bet they're the same
uncanny valley effect for talking to
someone you can't simulate a human
without someone simulating something
that's very close to human and that
would be unethical even if it was
possible but you could hijack the vision
center you could use all those same
little tips and tricks that the brain
has been using for 12 millions of years
of evolution to just quietly make you
not notice things if you if you walked
here like this and quietly rooted
yourself around an obstacle without even
seeing it you're already using those
tricks and yes I have footnotes
you could just tell your vision Center
to just quietly remove things or add
things in you could teleport to remote
office by saying to your implant or
whatever it is you want to go there it
is paint your vision with that it would
paint you into the vision of the people
there but if you can do that then you
can start to remove things as well those
implants could could use a sort of hats
that we've talked about to quietly
remove objects and people and anything
to start off with right this would just
be used on annoyances it would be used
on the baby that's crying on the plane
it would be used on the jerk who keeps
leering at you at the bus stop every day
but eventually it would start to roll
out and roll out you'd be able to block
someone you won't appear in their
perceptions and they won't appear in
yours I'm sure there are going to be
people out there without implants but
increasingly as it becomes more and more
normalized like smartphones are today
they're going to find themselves in a
kind of a Twilight Zone where a lot of
people are ignoring them the same way
that people get better customer service
by tweeting someone than they do by
calling up a landline and okay there are
people we're going to try and get around
this right they're going to be moments
of human ingenuity but
it was really expensive to get that
photo made by the way just the
skywriting cost alone but in general
right people would be okay with this
because no one here could tell me the
last person who unfriended them on
Facebook not with certainty because you
can't remember everyone your friends
when you don't check every day and it
doesn't notify you and it's not
particularly offensive when it happens
they're just not appearing anymore
you've just forgotten about so once
we're having with that the technology
can start getting better and better and
better
it can start blocking objects and
concepts and ideas and it can start to
just automatically work out the things
that your brain flinches away from an
automatically start to block them and
people will start sharing block lists
right it won't be monolithic you won't
be brought in from on high but you will
just tend to block the same things your
friends block because if you don't you
keep noticing the elephant in the room
and you keep being the author while a
dinner party who keeps talking about
things that people don't understand or
alternatively your friend is and will
you please shut up about that Dave we
don't know what you mean literally we
don't know what you mean people ships
homes offices entire cities just just
quietly arrays imagine crowds of people
just sliding past each other on the
street just by unspoken unknown mutual
consensus just removing each other I
mean China Mabel talked about listening
in his book the city in the city right
but those two cities were divided by
tradition and etiquette and occasional
violent retribution and tourists just
had to fit in then we none of that
instead of going to war feuding nations
could just block each other right no
citizens implants would be will be
legally mandated just quietly edit the
other country out maybe it gets the
point where you don't know the other
world exists until you're an adult maybe
children just kept from it because you
don't want to talk to those people until
then it's just a rumor is just bumps in
the night and explanations for ghost
stories and then you get to being 18 or
21 or whatever you have a look in the
other world to see what it's like and
terrible never ever want to go back
there they'll say there are people who
blocked everyone and we'll never know
for sure but I could look out as a full
house like this and not know if my eyes
eating over the people from another
world maybe there's someone else on
stage and I'm just walking and talking
around them because that's what my
implant lets me do which means there is
one little question left over what
happens when you edit out the idea of
implants from people who have implants
because they're going to be people hate
the idea maybe they were fitted with
them from birth maybe maybe they were
given them for work and have to have
them but they hate the idea that the
thing that is heading into their art
through their eyes into their brain
isn't reality and how would that be any
different from me being on the stage
right now telling a story and you
immediately dismissing this as science
fiction ignore that hitch behind your
ears it's probably nothing my name's Tom
Scott have a good night all right yeah
the camera Tom call agent Dunham all
right